[Music]
the people in Iowa get to make the first
choice the entire country indeed the
entire world is watching to see what
happens right here in Benton County how
many people here have already made a
phone call or knocked on a door will you
raise your hand because I want to
personally thank you and invite
everybody else to come join with us
thank you thank you thank you thank you
now we want more people to be able to
raise their hands before February 1st
my role is making sure in these last ten
and a half or 11 days that we're doing
everything we can to get out there speak
with as many potential caucus goers as
we can and make sure we get him out to
caucus for Hillary my name is Brett and
I'm calling with the Hillary Clinton
campaign here in Polk County how are you
this evening tonight I am making phone
calls making sure that everybody who's
told us they're coming is for sure
coming that they know their caucus
location and that they'll be there oh
it's just it's just volume it's knocking
those doors making those phone calls you
know TV ads talk at you radio ads talk
at you we have a chance to talk with
people and we find that's what's most
effective in the final days last weekend
I called over 220 people in two hours
I was also out walking for six hours
every weekend this month we've knocked
more doors in the weekend before despite
the sub-zero temperatures in fact when
it's colder people are nice for to you
because they really know you're
dedicated to your cause thank goodness
for hand warmers which is not anything
that I knew about they don't have them
in Hawaii we did move from Oahu to Des
Moines Iowa in order to participate in
the caucus and to volunteer for Hillary
didn't know anybody in Iowa but we
thought well this is the year I'm not
very politically active usually but my
son at age 2 was diagnosed with autism
as a first lady she helped develop the
health insurance program which my son
actually is on I've had a few people you
know just closed the door on me but
there's a lot of busy people out there
so it's you know just getting them to be
willing to take that time I know that
there are people that are kind of
gun-shy about oh I don't want other
people to know who I support you know
quite honestly it's a little
disappointing that only about 10% of
people get out to the caucus that's a
little disappointing but on the other
hand I know it's not easy to ask people
to get out I'm sure it's gonna be called
that night the last seven months I've
knocked a few of your doors and made a
lot of phone calls so many of you in
this room if not all of you know a few
of you hung up okay I know some of you
are already committed to caucus for me
and I thank you I know some of you are
on the fence I hope we can move you over
and I know some of you are still trying
to make up your mind and I hope that I
can earn your support at the beginning
everybody was undecided now a lot of
people are decided but you know not sure
if they're gonna come to the caucus or
not February first I will be practicing
I will be the precinct captain which
means that I am kind of running the show
for Hillary supporters in my
neighborhood when the doors open making
sure that we're visible in the corner of
the gym or library wherever we're at to
make sure people know where Hillary
Clinton supporters are and where they
should be the entire night and to help
bring more people over to Hillary I mean
we are thinking there may be some
undecideds it's possible that the
O'Malley supporters may not be viable
and we're going to do our best to
convince them to come with Hillary the
Iowa caucus you have to do it the right
way you can't just come in late and try
and throw things together in a hurry and
so we've been working methodically since
April to earn every vote in every corner
of the county and every corner of the
state and I feel like we're gonna see
some great results on February the first
but I can't do any of this alone I need
you I need you knocking on doors and
making phone calls I need you caucusing
on February 1st for me and then I need
you to help me
when Iowa in November and go into the
white house as your partner thank you
all so very much
[Applause]
[Music]